how about John from Dallas are you here
John right up front man you guys Rock I
flew out from Dallas to attend the Babel
Eve show my girlfriend and I decided to
attend the show back in October before
he was even announced you guys are
psychic
we got an argument one night and I told
her I was gonna leave for a couple
nights to give her some time to cool
down well she thought I was leaving for
good so I left and awoke the next
morning only to find she had stolen my
email account Facebook account and
deleted them both I take it she's not
with you this evening John empty chair
next to John okay maybe she was in the
bathroom I think I can't wait to see her
man then she really [ __ ] up because
she was a Verizon employee and she took
my cell phone off my account and placed
it on her employee account and suspended
it so I had no access to it I what did
you do I was proud you wanted a little
space and she was like now I want to
destroy your life
but John got back at her I reported this
finally got my phone back and she got
fired after working for Verizon for four
years people applauding unemployment in
this economy they're all like there's a
job open I didn't let it get me down and
flew out by myself anyway right on could
Charlton Heston tell her to keep her
damn dirty hands off my thanks her name
is Ellie thanks John from Dallas well to
least I could do John
keep your damn dirty paws off my phone
Eddie you stinking Verizon employee you
know I found out this week that charlton
heston
in Greece is always build as Charlton
Easton I got chills they're multiplying
all of his posters and when he's built
in Greece not that he's in many movies
in it before being dead and all but
whenever he was they would always build
a Miss Charlton Easton because Heston in
Greek apparently means to be shat on
because his phone the peril means to
[ __ ] on someone
I remember that character did he sing
summer lovin so that's why he changed
his name in Greece you've got the
musical not the movie Grease the country
Kevin I think this is where we're happy
this is where we're having a
communication breakdown I'm making like
Danny Zuko jokes you're not gonna make
black Glen like why won't he pick this
up this is genius well genius might be a
little too far baby was funny
I liked overestimate but in the back of
my head I was gone Chung Heston was in
Greece and as I've knew he was one of
the teachers and I was like oh yeah he
was in the gas station I was like wait
that was Wayne's World
because the governor station I was
having in the back of my head like my
money grease in the country of Greece
you know Greece when they say diplomatic
immunity
yeah foreign nation yeah the nation of
Greece all right when I hear that the
language of Greek esten means to [ __ ] on
someone so instead they're he's Charlie
Easton that's correct
[ __ ] Greece in theater I apologize for
that tangent I will do less of that in
2012
[Music]
you